[Music]
we are learning more about the
importance of real estate and efforts by
the super wealthy to hide sums of their
money the details come from the massive
leak of financial documents known as the
pandora papers billions of dollars have
been secretly invested in london
properties reportedly including millions
by the royal family of qatar and a
ukrainian billionaire who's already
under investigation by the fbi holly
williams has more from the british
capital
each house is really a medium-sized
hotel that's the best way to think about
it with seven star luxury
this is one of london's most expensive
residential streets the bishops avenue
or billionaires row to the locals
and driving this vintage aston martin is
trevor abramson who sells luxury
properties here to some of the world's
wealthiest individuals including this
seven-bedroom house currently on the
market
this property
will cost you 25 million dollars
and it's a bargain at that
with its indoor pool just waiting for a
new owner to be filled home gym private
cinema and master bedroom suite with
gold-plated fittings it's fit for a
foreign prince or a russian oligarch
abramson told us his clients are
addicted to london real estate if my
crime is that i'm a drug dealer
for residential properties and i feed
them what they want
guilty as charged
jokes aside there's no suggestion
abramson's done anything illegal but the
pandora papers reveal uk properties
worth nearly five and a half billion
dollars according to those who've
analyzed them purchased through offshore
shell companies that hide the identity
of the owner using a shell company means
that no one need ever know that the
asset is yours indeed the british
government probably doesn't know
duncan haynes is an anti-corruption
activist many of the property owners are
not accused of any crime but haynes
argues the secrecy permitted by british
law is an invitation to money laundering
accepting bribes
is illegal for a public official
and if you then
invest the money you've received in
those bribes and people help you do it
then they are facilitating money
laundering money laundering is illegal
the pandora papers expose a london
property empire worth nearly 700 million
dollars amassed by the ruling family of
azerbaijan and their close associates
according to those who've examined them
the state department says officials in
azerbaijan a former soviet republic
often engage in corrupt practices with
impunity
if you've got enough money to spend then
you can get away with all sorts of
things
some uk lawmakers have proposed new
rules forcing property investors to
reveal their identities but duncan
haynes claims the british government is
dragging its feet we need to address our
achilles heel corruption undermines our
system and makes us weaker you're saying
if americans care about democracy and
freedom they should be against money
laundering and corruption no matter
where it occurs in the world
absolutely and especially when it occurs
in the capital city of one of your
closest allies for cbs morning's holly
williams london
oh you can try to hide your money in
your properties but you can't hide from
the pandora papers that's for sure